good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is Tuesday hey
cloud hyd is hyd hi Jax hi everyone I'm
doing good it's only Tuesday I literally
can't believe it but I'm doing good just
chugging along trying to try and make it
you know yep I
I definitely know I am so sleepy today
that's why I'm still wearing a robe but
this is my morning toast robe so I feel
like it's acceptable to wear on the show
and it's just the most comfortable thing
in the entire world I had accidentally
left it at our studio for most of
quarantine but I just went and got it
back and I'm truly in heaven sitting
here in it and I hope that everyone
doesn't mind that I'm wearing a robe and
you have a sleepy tone to your voice I
know I was so tired last night I fell
asleep at like 10:30 which is crazy for
me and then I woke up like 11 hours
later and I'm still just in a fog and I
didn't take anything like it this was
unnatural so I have been feeling this
morning as well just like not great and
I think it might have to do with the
fact that we both got shots yesterday
you think like it's possible I don't
know that would be crazy we both got
shots yesterday my arm is killing me
when I was laying in my bed rolling over
I was like I woke up from the pain in my
arm and I'm a side sleeper and my arm my
left arm was like totally out of
commission so not being able to like
flip quickly onto my left side was
devastating for me last night truly yeah
no I woke up to a very painful arm well
I was like bragging last night
everyone's arms hurt and I was like mine
doesn't hurt I'm like so healthy and
like literally the second I said that my
arms started to hurt
welcome to the club we have fabulous
past five stories we don't have TV recap
because there was nothing on television
last night very sadly and I literally
just can't be bothered to turn my TV on
anymore like I'm officially I think like
done with television you know quarantine
takes many different phases you know
there's something there faces that I was
on my palette on every single day and
then like the last two weeks I did I
palette
and once so things happen people change
and I think you just gotta go with the
flow yeah my flow is currently like
laying in bed in the same position for
12 hours watching tick tock my flow
today is gonna be a cleaning flow
because my laundry is piling up and then
I'll be like oh my god I had such a
productive day I clean my whole
apartment and then I'll be feel really
good about laying in bed and watching
Potomac all night Oh actually I'm going
to be productive as well today I have my
first therapy session via zoom that's
exciting
sorry telehealth whatever it's called
that's exciting yeah I'm getting ready
to like get in my feelings um I love to
put not like makeup right like it's
after well it just depends who you are
you know like because I feel like I
would wear makeup because I just want to
paint the whole picture of who I am you
know you know it would be it wouldn't be
false of you to show up without makeup
but I feel like if I show up with makeup
on like that's like I'm not even like
being raw and exposed to my therapist
which is like what I want to be yeah I
think that I think youyou could go
without makeup and and that's you just
being comfortable but I would be being
uncomfortable not wearing makeup
I understand no that's it's just
interesting to think about like you know
the logistics of telehealth yeah it's
quite logistical um so we have a
fabulous show for you guys today
fast five and that's pretty much it um I
we are gonna talk about Kaitlyn Bristowe
right and I have so many thoughts yes we
are that's our first story so let's just
jump right into it into the past five
stories that you yes you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay you're Jax
excuse me oh I have something to say go
and what I have to say it's so simple
you know yet so complicated today's
episode is brought to you by stamps comm
for all of our sakes we need to avoid
crowds any way we can right now but what
if you need to go to the post office
what if you need postage to send out
letters and packages
don't worry stamps.com is here to help
with stamps comm you can print postage
on demand and skip the lines and get
crowds at the post office plus you can
actually save some money with discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office plus
that wasn't enough stamps calm also now
offers UPS services with discounts up to
62 percent and no UPS residential
charges stamps.com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer in the safety and
comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else you are hunkering down
whether you're a small business sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products or you're just working from
home and need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it with these
simply use your computer to print any
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a free package pick up or drop
it in the mailbox no human contact is
required it's that simple and like we
said the stamps.com you get great
discounts to five cents off of every
first-class stamp and up to 62 percent
off shipping rates stamp Starcom is a
no-brainer
especially now saving you time and money
and keeping you safe during these crazy
times
right now our listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
toast
that's stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast
stay safe with stamps calm love it sign
on stamp on okay first story very
exciting news that's about five years
overdue but we'll get it we'll take it
when we get it the bachelorettes Kaitlyn
Bristowe is joining Dancing with the
Stars for season 29 she says I'm so
honored so last night ABC is doing their
greatest of all time bachelor
bachelorette seasons where they condense
the season into one night I had not been
tempted to watch at all until last night
because I loved Kaitlyn season and I
loved me guys um I didn't watch though
unfortunately but I was really tempted
and I'm kind of wishing that I had
because at the end she was on like a
zoom situation with Chris Harrison where
he let her know surprised her with the
news that she is going to be on the next
season I'm Dancing with the Stars and if
you've been following her journey this
is like her biggest dream she thought it
was never gonna happen because Mike
Fleiss had pretty much blacklisted her
from Dancing with the Stars and so she
was just over the moon and it's very
sweet yeah if you're new to the bachelor
franchise you might not
that she actually like had a position on
the cast pretty much secured after her
season and Mike Fleiss took it away and
said quote he doesn't want people
getting famous from his show yet like he
doesn't want people to be like pursuing
theme after the show but it's fine when
it's any other man who's been on the
show just not Kaitlyn Bristowe right
he's a trained dancer she's amazing
watch her head I think that she could
win like this has always been the
logical next step for her and they just
never let her have it and I don't know
what changed over a bachelor HQ but I'm
just so glad that justice is being
served like that there's a small iota of
justice being served today yeah and um
snap like snatchler had of theory that
um Jayson and Katelyn might get engaged
like live on zoom' like after there's
goat thing aired and I thought it was
actually a good call but during the
airing Kaitlyn was like live chatting
and they were going live on Instagram
like during her commercial breaks and
someone did a Q&A like have you and
Jason looked at rings together and
Kaitlyn said yeah so then I'm like right
maybe they're not getting engaged
tonight because like she wouldn't like
teased it like that so I was curious
like what you know if there's a surprise
like what could it be and I never would
have thought this it's it's so fabulous
like I just I love a full circle justice
moment you know yes me too and like I
would have assumed that maybe it was too
late you know even if someone wanted her
to be on it like it's just the time has
passed but there's no time like the
present and that's the moral of the
story yes she's gonna do great she's
such a good dancer um interestingly
enough I went over to Shawn booths
Instagram last night just to like see
you know cuz it is a pretty awkward like
they relive their engagement last night
and they are no longer together and I
from what I could tell like they're not
like the friendliest of exes so he was
on his Instagram story saying like you
know he's been getting a lot of interest
in his love life you know today
especially and he doesn't know why today
it's like yeah you do it's cuz your
season is airing but okay continue and
he said he actually is seeing someone
new and he's been keeping it private
it's like low-key but he just wanted to
let his followers know
so yeah there's an update first on boots
I would love to know who he's dating I
know he runs in like a in a Nashville
like thirsty circle which I would love
to be a part of I'm not saying that like
that thing it's noisy but it's it's
pretty fabulous mm-hmm yeah I feel like
we might know who he state like who he's
dating might be like a semi-famous
person oh I mean that's what I one can
only hope
yeah that's why I'm saying like I wonder
who he's dating I feel like we might be
able to like put some piece of the
puzzle together I am sure that someone
listening to this show like someone has
to know like let us know DMS yeah I'm
sure it's someone fabulous Sean boo it's
like for a while he was my favorite
person in bachelor nation like if I
could be on The Bachelor like I would
want him as my leading man like I was
obsessive and I just kind of be kind of
fizzled but like he's still like super
hot um I just thought it was interesting
like there's all this stuff is now
happening for Kaitlyn and I just wanted
to see what Chum booth was up to so I
like went over it is Instagram and he's
good at his gym is up and running that's
exciting
mm-hmm I'm happy for him well speaking
of bachelorettes I don't know if you saw
this but Bachelorette star Hannah Brown
rescued a man while rafting with her
family Hannah brown Hannah brown rescued
a man in the Osio River during a
whitewater rafting outing with her
family in Tennessee over the weekend the
former Bachelorette star allegedly
pulled a man to safety into her family's
raft after his raft flipped over
according to his girlfriend who detailed
the ordeal on Twitter after she was paid
handsomely by Hannah's I mean this is
like the most conveniently timed story
and I just want to say I have been
whitewater rafting in camp and not only
was it the worst day of my life
I too was rescued I literally fell out
of my boat and someone pick me up so I
don't know where that was you that was
your Hannah brown the girl tweeted that
she was on the river with us our raft
flipped and her family and her and her
family were on the trip with us and she
ended up pulling my BF onto their raft
after the current took him I didn't know
who she was but her mom said she just
went Dancing with the Stars and that she
was a Bachelorette I
it's strange Astoria I'm sorry for being
like so negative but like why would I
believe this yesterday after the show I
saw this story like I mean oozes
Instagram and I was just like but no
this is just like PR 101 you know become
a hero ya know it's there it's quite
heroic um it makes me want to go
whitewater rafting but I really just
want to do anything oh my god I can't
tell you like how much that one trip at
summer camp to go whitewater rafting
like changed my life in such a negative
way like it was the worst day of my life
I literally never forget it it was
horrible there weren't like enough
whitewater waves to like keep us maybe
like need to paddle so much and then it
became like so treacherous it's such a
dangerous activity for like a summer
camp with kids I just I have such strong
feelings about whitewater rafting like I
will literally never go I would rather
dead-ass jump out of a plane yeah I mean
there's varying levels of whitewater
rafting there's like the crazy Rapids
and then there's what we did which was
pretty much a lazy river um it's a
recreational yeah I mean I'm not crazy
about whitewater rafting but like when
you're in it it's really just like a fun
sensation and every once in a while I do
enjoy just doing activities that I
wouldn't normally do and I guess
whitewater rafting would be one of them
by the way same I'm all for trying new
things and I would love to you know do
something new and different as an
activity but whitewater rafting like I
am so scarred from this day at a camp
like it was just the longest day ever we
got so sunburned we like literally like
wrote ourselves into like a bush of
poison ivy like it was just the worst
[ __ ] day never again never again well
maybe if you go again you'll run into
Hannah brown oh yeah so back to Hannah
brown I don't know why I like not to be
like such a [ __ ] but like something
about this story just like doesn't seem
believable I know but the girl posted it
on her Twitter so I don't really know
she also said she was being dramatic
when she said he was drowning he wasn't
suffocating or anything just being taken
downstream and she pulled him onto their
raft okay okay um okay ready for our
next story little exciting news
sure Kanye West files easy trademark for
makeup skin and hair care products wait
what
it looks like Kanye West is following in
his famous family's footsteps and
preparing to launch his own beauty brand
in the future the 43 year old fashion
designer who drops his first easy
collection in 2015
appears to be looking to expand his
empire on June 2nd he filed a Yeezy
trademark with the United States Patent
and Trademark Office which listed a
variety of beauty products in the filing
West's intellectual property holding
company mascot Holdings Inc registered
the trademark to cover everything from
cosmetics like lipstick concealer and
mascara to skin care like lotion toner
base masks and exfoliants it also
includes a variety of fragrance products
bath and body products and hair care
such as shampoo conditioner gel and dye
well this always becomes a news story
like whenever a celebrity files a
trademark and it's very possible that
like he's just covering his ass legally
like just to make sure his trademark is
in every single category but the more
that I think about it like Yeezy as like
a like a beauty company like kind of
makes a lot of sense I could see it I
could also see like he just doesn't want
a beauty company called ez popping up
and then he has to deal like that
so you just filed a trademark
preemptively but I also could see like a
very easy vibe in my bathroom
yeah it could be one of the two but if
it is like him actually creating like a
beauty and skincare and like makeup
company um that's just so crazy because
I know that the Kardashians like don't
necessarily compete but like three
makeup companies in one family is like
actually too much I guess I guess it
might consider to be too much but like
I'll find a way yeah but I feel like
maybe um they want to become like the
next Fenty you know like Rihanna no I
could see it it's just when I read the
story I was like that's not the craziest
idea I've ever heard except for the fact
that his wife has a beauty company and
his sister-in-law and sneetches has a
beauty company exactly it's not the
craziest idea I've ever heard but like
you remember those storylines when Kylie
was like before she was really like
highly cosmetic she was just like the
biggest influencer in the world and she
would like entertain offers from Adidas
and Puma like she couldn't take both and
Yeezy was at the D this
honey would get mad if she didn't do the
adidas and then she signed the Puma one
and like he got all mad this just like
for someone who like got mad like this
is a weird thing to do I don't know I'm
sure eventually it'll all make sense yes
you know always make sense cuz they
don't not make sense no and there there
are a lot of things but there are united
front like they don't release anything
usually with that like everyone knowing
about it everyone being on board I mean
this is just so interesting like Kanye
in a lot of ways like in his business
remind me of Elon Musk like I don't
understand a lot of it because it's like
he was just on GQ saying he's like
making like tractors remember yeah he
was in it
and they know that Yeezy like the
company is mostly um like the sneakers
and that's like really what the money is
but then they also have those fashion
shows and I've actually never seen a
human being where you see clothing have
you yes okay like not a Kardashian no I
mean yeah Kim wears it but like jackets
and it's hard to get and it's expensive
and that's why people don't wear it and
it sells out so quickly and then it's
had stock X and you're going to buy
socks and like you've got a easy jacket
instead I just don't ever like have a
memory of seeing Jeezy clothing for sale
anywhere do you
I guess not I don't think the only
places would be for sale are on resale
sites because like when they launched it
where did they sell it like egg easy
calm and it goes so fast if any of the
toasters have an item of Yeezy umm
apparel I do own a pair of Yeezys
sneakers I never wear them I don't take
them out of the box because I don't want
to ruin them and they were gifted to me
um by Kanye West's
team for you know my iconic performance
of the closed on Sunday on the morning
toast in 2019 Claudia that was beautiful
yeah it really was
um okay you ready for our next story a
little update on something I think we
were all kind of curious about but not
really because nobody really gives you
[ __ ] about the Oscars but let's live in
a world where we pretend like we do
because we're 25 I know
honestly I can't imagine a world where I
care I know but like
I'm sure we had said like what are they
gonna do for the Oscars no movie yeah
yeah yeah here's your answer
2021 oscars are postponed to April 25th
the latest date ever and films eligible
through February 28th as widely expected
and endlessly speculated the other shoe
has dropped and Oscar is on the move the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences said Monday morning that the
93rd Academy Awards originally scheduled
for February 28 2021 will now take place
on April 25th the latest date ever since
Oscar started the TV era in 1953 that's
when are they supposed to be February
and said they're April do you know what
a dramatic [ __ ] article for like I'm
one month two months [ __ ] delay yeah
but that way they can make up for the
delay that has been the past three
months because things are going back
into production now I don't know if
you've been seeing but um things are
back unless you're in New York yeah
unless you're in New York but um now my
concern is like what movies are gonna be
eligible like king of Staten Island is
the only thing that's come out and
trolls know good movies have come out
well trolls will wit will get nominated
for an animated for sure but which
movies have gone straight to demand that
were like critically acclaimed every
ghosted critics it's the critically
acclaimed that oh and I was talking to
your husband last night because but they
also all come out around Christmastime
anyway the critically that's true that's
true yes we're not really missing
anything right now what did my husband
say I was talking to your husband I'm
about king of Staten Island because he
loved it and I was like sure cuz like
him and I are usually on the same page
like we both have taste um and I was
talking him about it and I actually was
super curious I went on Rotten Tomatoes
because we're on Tomatoes to me it's
like the most illegitimate website it's
honestly like it is the pinnacle of like
corruption and bureaucracy because none
of those [ __ ] ratings make sense and
like the movies that I love like one
time me and you looked up Georgia rule
like one of the most iconic movies of
all time Lindsay Lohan Felicity Huffman
Jane Fonda like and I cut Garrett
Hedlund like an iconic film if you've
never seen jour
we'll go watch it it had like a 4% it
was just and that's what I knew it from
that moment I just knew Ron Tomatoes was
a sham and a crooked website and this
king of Staten Island movie now
regardless if if you love Pete Davidson
or not like you're really you cannot
deny that it was a bad movie like it was
just movies require like plots and
resolutions and it had neither of those
and it had a 70% and I'm like Georgia
rule is like literally the most
intricate [ __ ] special maybe of our
time and it got a lesson as king of
Staten Island movies I mean that website
is just so corrupt like I can't explain
it
okay I haven't did ring so I can't speak
to I mean whether or not it's correct
I knew that Rotten Tomatoes was a
crooked website when um I watched this
movie called the lobster that was maybe
one that no I would say not maybe
definitely the worst movie I've ever
seen like my life was measurably worse
for having seen that movie and I went
and Ron Tomatoes and it had a 98%
literally 90 it like one of the top
scores ever I literally couldn't believe
it I'm like oh okay well this might make
you feel better because I actually saw
hidden figures had a 93 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes tonight my enough not
high enough first of all second of all
like if they even thought of getting
giving him like ever of course art is
subjective of course you know at the end
of the day artists subjective but
nothing about hidden figures was
subjective like everything about it was
having is like who literally it is
undeniably a fabulous movie so if they
were just to give it like a bad score
they would immediately show how corrupt
they are you don't I mean they're very
strategic yeah sure
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story oh my god that was so fast
now we're just breezing through what can
we say maybe I'll just sing like two
pickups Mars I'm ready for the final you
can now pay thousands of dollars to talk
to celebrities for 10 minutes
thanks cameo some boarding cooped-up
celebrities have apparently hit peak
quarantine on are now offering zoom
calls with fans for hundreds and even
thousands of dollars cameo a start at
the lets you pay celebrities for
personal video messages now lets users
book a 10 minute zoom call with
well-known people the costliest are
farmer football star Brett Favre for
$5,000 X and Sync singer atlantes bass
for twelve hundred and fifty dollars and
skateboarder Tony Hawk for $1,000 so
cameo has shifted for quarantine you can
now zoom with a celeb for $1,200 can I
just say the Cameo is a platform um it's
like a great idea and I love that there
you know this is an uncertain time
they're shifting their their strategy
and I think that's great because like
everyone is zooming and I think that's
great no shade to cameo as a brand but
like talking and like looking at cameo
like the website like never doesn't make
me depressed what the [ __ ] is Tony Hawk
doing for a thousand dollars just like
Tony Hawk just made a thousand dollars
the only problem with cameo is like they
don't really have stars um well it
depends on who you're wanting to hear
from you know and they really have so
many reality stars and I feel like
people love to get it from like and like
podcasters and digital influencers and
those are the people that like of course
but like it's a celebrity app and like
it's just not really that celebrity II I
feel like if it's it's become really big
recently yeah I mean I'm just I'm on the
website I just want to UM show you like
it's not to be so rude but like I've
never heard of most of these people okay
Chris Harrison is so far oh my god you
know what they have yeah I mean I'm
totally gonna get one oh my god I'm dead
so this is oh this is actually
interesting they have a category of
people whose all their proceeds go to
coab in nineteen relief which is
fabulous and they have Susie Essman
Susie from Curb Your Enthusiasm oh my
they have to get one for men I've got
three hundred and twenty-five dollars
see okay it's worth it it's worth it who
else then it's like you see a Bronwyn
Eileen Davidson okay who do you think oh
let's play game who do you think is more
expensive Bronwyn or Eileen Davidson
I think Eileen Davidson right now cuz
her time I think is more valuable
you would be right Braun Bronwyn Windham
Berg
$45.00 like kill me so sad and Eileen
Davidson is 100 yeah cuz Eileen Davidson
like she she hike works and stuff and
Bronwyn is a celebrity my god yeah oh my
god there's something I'm not gonna say
hey but like there are some people on
they hair like who literally just make
me cringe I can well let's keep playing
this game this is a good game okay um
give me a minute you could just like
keep talking while I find people ok
musicians I'm gonna can never heard of
any of these people yeah it's not really
like it's more so reality in digital
celebs not like you Envy stars yeah I
guess that's true it's just um it's the
policy it's like the perfect company
they just need more famous people on
there no it's a great idea people love
it people who I used to dnal the time it
was really fun people love to get them
everyone wins
I mean we got cameos from Daymond John I
got one from Damon shining you got one
from Bethenny oh my god yes I love that
today I miss her so much I know every
day I'm like just like what would Betty
think about this ya know she's the type
of person who's like opinion I really
value even though like I don't know her
ya know a hundred percent but we do know
her because like we've lived with her
for so long you know I know everything
about her yeah okay well there are no
Housewives on this week so there's not
gonna be epic all time
there's no Housewives on this week so
there's not gonna be TV recap um so it's
gonna be like the short episodes this
week because there's no New York and
there's no Beverly Hills
yeah but pump rules is on tonight the
third chapter of the reunion we have
just like so surpassed this reunion like
culturally even just within the show
like so much has happened like it's so
silly to watch this like it's just it
feels every time for the last two weeks
watching the reunion like I feel silly
like I feel like I've evolved past it
yes you know what I'm going to say that
the reunion of the Vanderpump rules part
3 of Union is optional um if you if you
watch it and you want to discuss it
great same for me I don't know where
I'll be tonight at 9 p.m.
I know I know physically where I'll be
but like mentally I just can't say so
unclear if we'll be watching I I adored
that idea and you know now that it's
optional
sure that I'll watch it like what he
feels like homework I like I immediately
don't want to do it I'm like take him
back to like middle school exactly
so um okay I feel so weird but I
genuinely think that's all she wrote
I think they don't sell see or Treat
apparently she's like busy and she has
all this stuff going on today and so
she's done writing think Oh actually she
said no Claudia I'm not time writing
promote your special okay Mike how many
special comes out in two weeks you can
pre-order it on iTunes you can click the
link in my bio on Instagram on girls no
job or you get a search disgraced Queen
onto iTunes and preorder it I would
really appreciate it thank you guys so
much for the support so far I think is
too much chosen to the morning doesn't
want to show we go live money the Friday
10:30 a.m. is newcomer you should
support you guys I need you please if
you to subscribe news video thumbs up
we're also available podcast anywhere
podcast to be found that's why I teacher
Public Radio I already cuts all the
places where we lose podcast - more
interesting we are we love you guys have
a great day a bye